[Music]
anytime I get a chance to reflect hope
it always begins with what the great
Antonio Gramsci call a critical self
inventory because hope is in fact the
kind of notion you can never really wrap
your heart mind and soul around it you
have to give an account for the hope
inside of you so it's SS tential it's
very personal it may be groundless but
it can be so full which is to say what
keeps you going how do you account for
the brief trek between mama's womb and
tomb what has gone into the shaping and
molding the situating and locating of
yourself and soul in relation to others
knowing that the self is always
connected intimately shaped by others so
I begin any talk about hope let alone
justice with acknowledging that I am Who
I am because somebody loved me somebody
cared for me why do I begin not this is
not sentimental this is what I call
revolutionary piety piety is
acknowledging one's indebtedness to the
sources of good in one's life is trying
to account for the forces that have
pushed won the win at one's back in
whatever progress one has made in life
and sometimes the progress is simply
negative not to commit suicide this
morning that's a breakthrough how do you
do that by acknowledging the ways in
which the indebtedness that you have
allow the afterlife of those who came
before to be manifest in your life if
the best of what they are is enacted and
embodied in the best that you're
attempting to
now in the academic context a lot of
people call that or Emersonian
perfectionism it's a two kind of
reliance on the self that's forever
ascending it's always nonconformist as
always cuts against the grain it's
always contrary it's always
acknowledging the degrees of wit it is
subversive the worst and preserving the
best now conservative and preservative
are two very different things
I am committed profoundly to tradition
to preserve not to conserve to preserve
the best and it ends up being over
against a status quo I come from a
tradition people's family been hated
chronically and systematically for 400
years and yet steel taught the world so
much about how to love I could just turn
on John Coltrane's Love supreme right
now sit down that's a love supreme love
supreme it goes back to the spirituals
and the ring shout that goes back to the
blues it goes back to Robert Johnson it
goes back to Ma Rainey and Bessie Smith
it goes back to Charlie Parker you could
feel that tradition through him and
we're living in a Trump moment which is
a moment of spiritual blackout which is
the relative eclipse of integrity
honesty decency across the board is not
just him you don't isolate him you don't
fetishize him as some individual he
represents the worst of the American
Empire the worst of American culture
the atavism the narcissism the
xenophobia the white male mendacity and
mediocrity that has a long history in
the country and now the chickens have
come home to roost what does that mean
it means that when we look at him we
also ought to look inside of ourselves
in our neighborhoods in our hoods and
our communities in our mosque and
synagogues and churches and in our Civic
institutions because of the long history
of white supremacy long history of the
rule of capital over the labor long
history of vicious forms of patriarchy
and homophobia that had worked in the
history he doesn't just fall from the
sky now why is that important well it's
because indeed if you're gonna count for
the hope inside of you didn't you have
to acknowledge that you've been on
intimate terms with catastrophe as
echoes of Sophocles Antigone all the
forces social psychic cosmic or against
you no serious talk about hope and
nephew tied to integrity why because the
virtues themselves in and of themselves
are too narrow
courage is never enough because Nazi
soldiers will be courageous and still be
thugs and gangsters you need spiritual
and moral dimensions to your courage the
old-school Romans called it fortitude
diffusion of courage and magnanimity
diffusion of courage and greatness of
character spiritual fortitude tied to
revolutionary piety to be what in John
Coltrane's language a real force for
good so what are we talking about we're
not talking about a discourse I hope
we're talking about being a hope hope
becomes more like a verb action like the
conclusion of a practical Aristotelian
syllogism which is an action and not a
proposition which is a live life a mode
of being in the world
[Music]